on the second day of her evidence the
nurse on trial repeated her denials Lucy
letby explained that on the 8th of June
2015 she'd been asked to swap shifts and
work at short notice in the neonatal
unit at the Countess of Chester Hospital
she was the allocated nurse for a
newborn twin baby a who was already
deteriorating when Lucy let B came on
shift
she and a colleague gave him fluids
through a tube and when the colleague
left the room to make some notes Lucy
Lippy said that the baby became jittery
his hands and feet went white and his
heartbeat dropped they put out an urgent
call for help but the resuscitation
attempts were unsuccessful
the nurse told the court she was stunned
to have walked through the door that
evening and straight into that situation
her defense team showed a WhatsApp
message exchange after the death of baby
a her colleague wrote you did amazing so
proud of you then another message hope
that doesn't sound patronizing it's
genuine you did Fab Lucy letby replied
no it's not patronizing at all
appreciate you saying that and thanks
for letting me do it but supporting me
so well
on her first shift back just Days Later
another newborn baby C died at Chester
Lucy letby broke down in tears as
another of the deaths that year was
analyzed in court
she denies harming any baby that she
cared for
Tom Parmenter Sky News Manchester Crown
Court